欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一章节我们来讲一下关于店铺卖什么产品,以及主推什么产品
很多时候我们的店铺有非常多的品类
但是呢,我们每个品类都想要
最后面你会发现你花的时间又多又忙
每天得到的结果又少
我们一定要清楚我们店铺到底在卖什么
而且我们的主推产品是什么
这些一定要明确
因为这些产品不明确
就会导致你产品布局混乱
就会导致你直通车推广没有方向
经常是推推A产品
又推推B产品
或者CD在不断的轮流更换
最后导致你的整个店铺的数据都不是正向积累
最终钱花了
但是效果却没有
所以我们在营一个店铺之前
一定要确定我们主要卖什么产品
以及我们要推广的是哪些品类
哪些产品
一定要明确
这样才能够做到事半功倍
才能够让我们的劳动更加有价值
那么接下来我们来讲两种类型的店铺
怎么样去确定我们卖什么样的产品
和主推什么样的产品
第一类店铺就是贸易型的企业
比如说他是靠选行业和选品来做店铺的
那么这种类型的企业就需要进行一个比较详细的一个数据的分析
或者是说一个产品跟国家选择的一个分析
那么我们来详细的看一下具体的时钞路径
这个贸易型的企业通常来说我们可以选择一些流量比较稳定
且需求大的行业
加上一些热销款作为切入去带动整个流量
把整个店铺做起来的一个切入口
当然也有些企业喜欢一些小众类目
小众类目虽然流量少
但是它的人群或者是购买的买家是非常精准的
也是比较容易成交的
这些流量大需求大的行业
它一般来说也是竞争比较大的
转化率会相对于小众行业的话
会小一点点
所以这个两个方向都可以
但是具体怎么样去选品
选行业
我们都是按照同样的一个路径去做选择的
那么接着我们来看一下具体的实操路径
第一个就是在市场参谋里面去选类目
首先第一个我们要在市场参谋先查一下类目
根据它的整体的数据维度去判断
比如说它的市场容量
增速等等
这些维度去判断这个类目是不是选你做
同时你有没有这方面的供应商
然后再根据这个类目去选择对应的榜单的产品
去优先突破这些热销的产品
因为这些产品在榜单说明已经被市场验证过
市场有需求
所以我们从这些榜单的产品切入
能够更快的进行流量的一个突破
第二个就是榜单选品
也就是我们找到这个榜单之后
去选里面的款式
选我们能做的
而且是我们有优势的款式
来进行去主打去做
第三个就是从流量参谋里面
去选一些内幕的热门品类
这个是以你需要确定内幕
再去选热门的产品
第四个就是从买家参谋里面
买家行业的偏好产品
第三个路径
净品店铺里面产品分组
根据它的排序
现在没有这个排序了
但是我们可以根据它的优秀组
去找到他们的产品
工厂型的企业呢
比如说它的内幕是不是已经定了
我只卖我自己的产品
这就是典型的工厂型企业
那么只卖自己的产品
还能不能选品呢
当然能
这是一定能选的
我们选的产品
还有里面它会有一些产品的功能
风格属性等等
都是可以选的
虽然说产品类型我们确定了
但是它的功能属性风格等等
材质等等
这些我们都是可以选的
因为不同的客户对这些产品的
季节的需求是不一样的
也会符合不同的买家的需求的
那么我们具体的实操路径就是
直接去参考同行
报款相似的产品
去上链接
去打造报品
也就是我们不用再去摸索了
直接参考他们
先做一轮新产品上架
然后再去直接推广去打造
那么选品也是跟这边有一些类似
第一个就是榜单选品
第二个就是市场参谋选品
接下来我们直接去后台实操演示一次给大家看
后期大家可以根据这个路径去选择产品
或者是说去确定我们主推的产品就可以了
首先我们打开这个后台
我们来看到市场参谋, 参谋这里的话我们先点击查行业
查完行业之后你要去进来看一下
这么多品类
往下还有很多嘛
你看看根据这些
这些维度去判断整个类目
哪个是你核心想要选择的
那么你就去选择对应的类目
比如说你选择的男装这个类目之后
我们在男装
点击一下男装之后他跳转到男装类目里面的一些细分的数据维度
比如说市场分析
商机分析, 买家分析, 还有就是
卖家分析
这个时候我们再来看
这个产品榜单
我们就去看这几个榜单
就可以了选择
比较符合我们的
或者是说
比较符合我们店铺原始就有的这些产品的款式风格类型
去发产品
去推广产品
那么这样
我们能够获得流量的机会就更多
同时我们能够打造爆款成功的概率就会更大
就按照这个思路这是一个路径
那么第二个路径就是我们要从
这个榜单是吧
我们从这个榜单里面
这里点进去之后会有非常多的一个
细分的维度比如说
这里有三个榜单
分别进去之后我们到这个板块
点到这里之后
这里有很多的
一个行业给你选择
也就是榜单的类型给你选择
关键词
核心这些关键词
体配的一些榜单
不同的关键词对应不同的榜单
或者是不同的
产品属性
这产品属性的关键词对应的
不同类型的产品
这些维度都可以去供你选品点内幕
这些维度都是合适的
所以你要多去浏览
多去挖掘一些新的款式
新的产品品类
无论你是冷门还是热门行业
只要这个板块它存在数据
你就一定有参考价值
我们在这些维度都是来参考的
而不是说
完全的照搬
当然我们搬部分的类型也是可以的
但是不是说你
一定完完全全要一模一样
就按照这个思路
接下来我们从
流量参谋这里去看
这里不是有个被目热门榜吗
那么这里面他会有非常多的一个
品类可以选的
你就来这里选品就得了嘛
接下来我们还可以在流量参谋
这里面有一个
板块就是
流量的去向
那么我们也可以从这个
行业优品这里去看一下
我们这里面还有很多
类型的产品是不是
这些我们是不是可以参考一个标题可以参考
价格起定量还有它的风格款式
无论你是热门行业还是冷门行业
都有参考价值
当然有些行业
比较小众或者是说流量比较少参考的东西就不多
如果这个维度的参考的数据少
你就去其他的维度去参考其他的板块参考不一定说
一定要非要这里有数据我们要灵活变通一点点不要
完全
受到
平台的限制一定要从多个维度去拓展
接着就是我们刚才讲的
比如说我们要去
竞品的店铺里面去找他们的产品
首先
很多时候
我们只要通过一个关键词去搜索就能够去找到那些自然排名没有广告为自然排名好的店铺
或者是说
我们之前
就已经知道我们的竞品店铺哪些做的比较好的同行比较优秀的店铺
我们直接打开了店铺之后
我们进入到他的产品分组这里面
你看他是不是
已经给我们分好的产品了
你看他这个是不是已经给我们分好了
我们直接点进去看
他们的这些是哪些产品
我们根据他的产品去选择
或者是根据他们的产品去看
我们跟他的差距是多大
是不是他已经帮我们分裂好了
你看点进去
点进去就是这些产品
你看这些产品
款式风格
无论你是
热门还是冷门
都可以用这个方法
因为
很多人他去外面学习的时候
他学到的方法就是按照这个分组
那么他肯定是像某个老师学的
如果是按照分组吧
那么他就给我们已经提供了最好的分考方向了
所以说
你只要去选得到
你那个行业优秀的店铺
把他的几个链接保存下来
每周每月都去看一下
那么你的选品
以及
选择推广的产品
都是非常有方向的
所以我们在做店铺的时候一定要知道我们要卖什么产品, 主推什么产品
特别是那些已经做了非常多类目的, 或者是非常多品种, 品类的那些店铺, 一定要注意
在你的自动车预算有限
一定要选择部分品类先切入
然后再通过这些品类的整体的一个爆款产品
优品, 实力品, 加上爆款
去带动你整个店铺的
其他品类的增长
因为有些
店铺是做一些
相关品类的,比如说
A买家
他既需要
C产品, B产品, 也需要
D产品
和F产品
那么我们前期可能只做
B跟B, 用直通车去拉升流量
那么只要这个B跟B能够给我们店铺引来A这类人
那么这类买家他也会对我们店铺里面DF产品
可能也会产生采购
所以我们是先从小去切入然后
把有限的资源用好
去拉升我们店铺的总的流量
然后再带动整个店铺的总的流量的增长
这就是为什么我们一定要明确我们的主推产品了
希望这节课能够让我们大家有一个核心主推产品的一个概念
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见